what's this what's this dune patrol jim
patrol's amazing god damn it what is
doom patrol i haven't seen doom patrol
do you know anything about it
no so i don't want you to give it away
but how do you how would you describe it
it's a 1960s comic
it was a 1960s comic
that got redone by grant morrison you
know the guy did happy and that's that
right grant
wonderful scottish comic book
graphic novel
tv shows rights rights rights right
that's right sort of sort of another
irvine welsh another he's another neil
gaiman in a way but but maybe less
prolific but just as interesting and
he's very much the antidote to to alan
moore whether he likes it or not they
were very
country you know there's a you know
watchman and his stuff was very
different and he read it in the 80s on
vertigo comics and doom patrol was
actually the original prototype i think
that x-men stole from
really there's a chief in a wheelchair
there's you know
elastic woman and you're a regular uh
i'm bizarre i'm doing my usual i'm not
gonna i don't even wanna mock shepard
but you do a lot of episodes i'm playing
constantine
wow but he's not called constantine
because grant wasn't allowed to put
constantine in vertigo comics in the 80s
so he was watching with nail and i of
course which you love and so he drew as
richard e grant so i got hold of grant
and i was like a buddy of mine was doing
um green lantern with him my buddy liam
sharp the artist who's doing green
lantern with the one they just done
that's just brilliant everybody goes
over right
now yeah um so
i can't cry like so it's
it's uh
it's richard e grant in
in with now he's like yep all right okay
i said with all the love in my heart i
don't think i can play quite that defeat
i think it'd probably be a bit more like
a drunk mad eye moody
he's like sounds good to me and he's not
actually a producer on the show but he's
he's so that's kind of your character
it's constantine it's consistent and
with some where do we find it where do
we find this
well the show was put out in dc as a and
they tried to pre-tease it by doing it
with teen titans and they put cyborg
into it jovan wade is wonderful and they
put him across and they tried to do it
that way the typical dc way of doing it
and nobody watched it
and they did this first season so you've
got
timothy
dalton matt bomer in bandages mark
shepard no matt no matt bomer
uh brendan fraser
diane guerrero from orange's new black
and encanto and a lot of other things
april bolby two and a half men remember
candace yep candy and
turn off so good cast no and then the
bad guys
two dick playing this alan tudor claimed
this diminutive mr nobody which is
really wonderful performance by him
jovan way playing cyborg
and who's running it jeremy carver who
ran
the interesting parts of of of
supernatural the 8 through 10 11. wow
and it was like
oh my god and i'll just tell you this
the entire town disappears up the ass of
a donkey in the second episode
have you seen it
oh i started it i haven't finished it
yet
so hbo bought it they went what the hell
this is genius really so it's not super
girl it's not the boys it's something
else it's about mental health
and it is truly disturbing and
beautiful
and funny and begs the question which is
why things have changed why isn't
brendan fraser in everything yeah well
he's because he's a resurgence now
there's a research as a result of doom
he's like he's he's this beautiful heart
in this i love this show i truly love
this show
and
it is
we've done three seasons three seasons
going into the four seasons wow
and
i'm a recurring character that you can't
kill so
yes doesn't do you have a deep voice
like that i have my voice that's a deep
voice i actually got to say the c word
in my first line